president Trump hinted that he would let
the u.s. rejoin the trans-pacific
partnership or TPP because you're all
talking about that well Liz Lemon settle
down just so you know this is a complete
turnaround on his position because one
of the first things he did as president
was pull the u.s. out of the TPP what do
you think any it's kind of strange well
it doesn't surprise me a bit I mean he's
flip-flopped on pretty much every
position and it's not good for the
country I read a great editorial
yesterday in the st. Louis post-dispatch
Billy can you put up that screen grab
from my computer I see that look trump's
flip-flops have become so commonplace
that americans are inclined to believe a
porn star more than they believe the
president of the united states i mean
that's what we've come to Eddie I'm
sorry I hate to interrupt you but that
screen grab you put up from your
computer yeah Billy do me a favor can we
see the other tabs you had open today
what are you talking about
any you have open tabs labeled look at
that look at that awesome black dicks
another one called
booze for kids and then down with Conan
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
me what's wrong with you Conan Billy
click on awesome black dicks see it's a
page honouring great african-americans
named dick and baseball great dick Alan
Z I'm I'm really embarrassed Danny
that's not what I when I saw it it's not
what I imagined yeah I know I know it's
not okay what about booze for kids all
right
oh there's one called booze for kids
that's just creepy is it what's creepy
about councilman Charlotte who's running
for re-election on a pro education
platform booze is for kids that's why
I'm endorsing her it's a bad slogan well
I'm not a manager okay hey I suppose
down with Conan that's one of the tabs
down with Conan's about some other guy
named Conan you're gonna say that right
no it's about you but the tab got cut
off Billy show them down with coding I
am it's completely supported he's down
with you I'm down with you Andy I'm I'm
really sorry I owe you an apology
I'm sorry you owe me three apologies I'm
sorry your creepy browser tabs weren't
creepy after all that's right so you
probably wouldn't mind if we just click
on the last one that says Burbank news
tab you know well you know there's no
need to do that really click on it any
witcher's targets
angers neighbors you pay seeds you
Philistines
you